hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're
continuing our coverage of the second
tournament in the 2019 grand prix this
one's in Latvia for Grand Prix's all
year each player will end up playing in
three of the tournaments that's already
predetermined they know which ones are
gonna play ahead of time but in this
particular tournament we have 16 players
they're playing a knockout tournament
they play a best of two the winner of
that's gonna move on to the round of 8
which we are in right now in round 2 if
you do not have a winner after two games
then you go to tie breakers we are in
tie breakers today our competitors
whites gonna be played by young today
stuff Duda he's the number one Polish
Grandmaster he's only 21 years old
extremely young talented player became a
grandmaster at the age of 15 if you have
not seen him play he is very very strong
playing the black pieces Chuck heerd mom
and you didn't have one of the strongest
players in the world right now and they
drew in the first tiebreaker so this
could be the deciding a game in at its
high breaker for those who didn't I'll
watch one of the earlier videos where we
went over the structure in the normal
classical style you get ninety minutes
per game and you have 30 extra minutes
after move 40 and you get 30 seconds
added on per move in tie breakers you
only get 25 minutes if after two games
there's no winner then you start going
into some faster games where you get 15
minutes and then it goes down from there
so we'll go and get started with yan
starts with Knight to f3 d5 c4 and then
after pani 6 we see b3 so this is the
English opening but then it starts
getting into the Larsen's opening with
pawn b3 not a common opening here from
whites but one that my guess is young
Christophe is pretty familiar with
Knight to f6 Bishop b2 so fast you ain't
kiddo onto the Queen side of the board
Bishop e7 pawn III Castle on the King
side Knight c3 do we do see an exchange
right here so the bishop pair eyeing
down the King side for black here pawn
c5 and then rook g1 was not expecting to
see this as
was analyzing the game a lot of
different options here Queen to c2 makes
a lot of sense castle on the kingside
that's an option if you want to stop
your opponent pawn age threes pretty
common here blocking the Knights come
down to g4 you have a good setup right
here you can control the server of the
board pawn to d4 at some point castling
just makes a ton of sense but he has
other plans that he plays rook to g1
Chuck here continues with a6 pawn g4 so
if you're gonna play rook to g1 you
definitely gotta start pushing on the
King side of the board palm b5 forcing
the bishop to come back here e to Bishop
b7 fianchetto getting ready to attack
the King side of the board here continue
to push forward g5 Knight moves to the
center of the board
Queen to b1 trying to activate as much
as possible could have also come to see
- did have some options there does not
look like he's gonna be castling his
king here
Knight to a d7 and Knight up here efore
Queen c7 so great development moved from
check here and he has a good setup the
King side Castle all of his pieces are
developed here now it comes down to can
he find a strong attack from wide
standpoint he really has to push on the
King side there's no reason to have the
setup unless you're gonna have a strong
attack so if he can do that he's gonna
have a good possibility of coming out
with a victory if he's not able to come
up with a strong attack
I do believe black's gonna be able to
dominate this game rook to g4 upon e v
just trying to control the center of the
board a little bit some of these
critical squares here on d4 and f4 as
well pawn to e3 just blocks off some of
the squares that the knight can come to
this is gonna be tough for white to deal
with so does want to stop the knight
coming there to be for now the rooks
start getting involved rook to e8 from
check here - Queen to c2 from young a
bishop f8 wants to allow the rook to
control the center of the board here h4
which is what I think White's should
have been doing for any long time now
starting to attack on the King side of
the board
Queen c6 and then D 3 you gotta continue
with the the play here
h5 makes a lot of sense starts to block
off all these critical squares that
black can go to yes eventually you'd
want to play pond III played King 2d to
your kings in the center of the board so
you do want to open up for the rook to
come over here swing to the king side of
the board but right now I don't think
it's the time you got to start pushing
here he decides to go and play d3 pawn a
five and then pawn a four and this is I
think the first critical mistake that
white has in of the game the pawn on a3
is exactly where it needs to be as soon
as it comes up here he loses control of
the be four square and that is a very
critical square because the knight can
come to b4 which is exactly what black
does attacking the Queen right here
Queen to c3 Queen six your centralizing
now it's attacking both this pawn here
on a b3 as well as the rook here on a g4
Knight comes back to d2 which is nice it
is playing double duty here this pawn is
now protected and the LightSquared
Bishop is now defending this rook here
on g4 but that's not what you want your
piece is doing it's not defense mode
from white here really should have been
attacking it on the King side of the
board pawn takes on a four when you see
in exchange here in the Knight b6
attacking at the pawn we see the knight
come up here to c4 doesn't have to worry
about that pond since it took here so
since the bishops still defending the
rook he can start to get this knight
involved into the game and he doesn't
want to make the mistake of taking with
his Knights here if he does that's gonna
be bad Bishop takes if the if the Queen
were to take right here then the Queen
can take the rook if we see the bishop
take then Knight 2 D 3 and this is the
the main move here of why this does not
work because this is forking the Queen
after the King moves then the Knights
gonna come up here and it takes oh
definitely look to have analyzed this in
the game you don't have a ton of time
but eventually you see that yes the
knight did not move away from d7 to here
without knowing that he could not take
this pawn so analyzing Rossi app can't
do that plays
to see four instead we see the night
start to come off the board Knight takes
e4 pawn recaptures work to DA twee now
have an open file here black immediately
takes control that with his rook King f1
Bishop c8 now the bishop and the Queen
both attacking the rook here on g4
besides go and bring his rook back does
have protection here but I guess he
decided he just doesn't want that under
fire bishop back to b7 now attacking the
knight here in the center of the board
pawn f3 supporting that but it also just
gives a little bit of air for black to
start to come and even attack this King
more than he already was here Queen g6
you can see nothing has been done on the
King side of the board from whites
because of that and he didn't have a
strong attack started out with that rook
to g1 and immediately played g4 didn't
do much after that he's now playing full
defense so the bishop and the Queen both
attacking the knight right here and I
comes back recognize he only has one
defender so night 2 f2 this is a purely
defensive move and then pawn h5 just
does not want to have to worry about any
pawns pushing forward this really stops
many of the threats that White is
thinking about later on in the game rook
to G 1 and then Queen down c2 getting
pretty aggressive on at the board Bishop
do you want attacking the Queen Queen
comes back to f5 King G 2 and this is
we've talked a lot as soon as Queens
come off the board we always say now's
the time to get the King above them to
the game it's a very valuable piece the
Queen's are not off the board not the
best time to get the King involved into
the game it didn't have a lot of
protection already but this is this is a
pretty open board state for black to
start to attack Knight to d3 getting it
involved Bishop to e2 attacking but
that's fine Pawnee for starting to put a
lot of pressure on his opponents here
pawn f4 trying to have a solid pawn
chain right here but there's just no way
to really stop south and that starts
with Knight takes on f4 and this is
check no really good way to defend this
we do see yan take with his pawn here
then pond III is the dagger no way to
come back from this attacking the
Knights right here but it's also a
discovered attack with the bishop this
is check so we already know that one
piece of material is gonna fall can't
retake with this Queen here both of
these rooks are completely dominating
the center of the board
Bishop to f3 stopping the check Bishop
comes down we do see an exchange right
here but then the pond to f2 and at this
point the game is over there's just no
way to stop all of the threats there's a
lot of different threats that are being
shown right here from black the first
one the most obvious is the pawn takes
on g1 ok that's one of them the second
one is just going to be the rook coming
down here to d3 that's both attacking
the king and forking the Queen right
here if the King takes then all of a
sudden you're gonna have the Queen come
down take both the rooks get involved
into the game there's gonna be no way to
hold on to that lots of different
variations that black has to checkmate
one of those maybe rook to g2 one
alternative to try to hold on to this
material but as we talked about the rook
comes down there's just no way to hold
on to this material couldn't have an
in-between move rook takes or Queen
takes here on f4 check eventually the
Queen is going to fall there's no way to
stop this once your opponent has your
Queen and they have a queen they could
just gobble up so much material at the
end the day Young Christophe would have
lost but he decided to go ahead and
resign after the pawn takes here on f2
so Shakir will be moving on to the
semifinals they are 4 left in this
tournament so congratulations to him
hard-fought battle in the tie breakers
young Christophe young Polish
Grandmaster played extremely well even
to get to the fourth game in the
heads-up match so I thank you guys so
much for watching we'll be back tomorrow
in round 3 to see who can make it to the
finals